We have already paid much attention to
the molecular structure of DNA.
In fact, we have two DNA circuits,
forming a double helix,
we can see the distinctive features of DNA.
In particular - five-carbon sugar
in the backbone of the molecule.
Let us number the carbon atoms.
This is 1 ', 2', 3 ', 4', 5 '.
We can see that at carbon atom 2 '
no oxygen.
There is no hydroxyl group attached thereto,
so we know this is not ribose.
This is deoxyribose. This is deoxyribose here.
Here too we have deoxyribose,
which tells us that we have two DNA strands
deoxyribonucleic acid.
I'll write it down.
This part of the chain is,
obtained by binding of deoxyribose
with phosphate groups and nitrogen base.
Deoxyribose.
What we should do if we want
instead
the two strands of the double strand of DNA -
how should we edit the left chain,
if we want to introduce it
as an information RNA circuit,
generated during transcription
of the single DNA chain on the right?
To turn it into RNA or to look like RNA,
at carbon 2 'we have to turn deoxyribose
in ribose.
So we will add a hydroxyl group here.
I can add a hydroxyl group here,
actually will stain the hydrogen atoms in white.
We will add one hydroxyl group here,
I will do it for all sugars
in the left chain spine,
if I want this to be a single RNA chain.
RNA is often single-chain.
Oxygen, and then hydrogen.
Addition of a hydroxyl group instead of
hydrogen,
tells us that this sugar is no longer deoxyribose.
This is ribose.
We already have a ribose in the spine,
which is a distinctive sign that
we have the backbone of RNA, ribonucleic acid,
instead of DNA, deoxyribonucleic acid.
You may think we are ready, but not completely,
because the RNA's nitrogen bases are slightly different than
those of DNA.
At DNA, the nitrogen bases are
adenine, guanine -
Adenine and guanine are nitrogenous bases with two rings.
Here, this is adenine.
This is guanine.
DNA also has cytosine.
I will make every base in a different color.
Cytosine and thymine.
This is cytosine here,
and this is thymine.
Cytosine and thymine are nitrogenous bases with one ring.
We call them pyrimidine bases.
Adenine and guanine are called purine bases.
It was a small negotiation.
In RNA we also have adenine,
as well as guanine.
We have cytosine,
but instead of Tymin, we have his very close relative -
uracil.
On the drawing
this nitrogen base - Remember when we started the video,
it was double-stranded DNA,
this nitrogen base here is thymine,
it forms hydrogen bonds with the adenine here.
If I want to make it a uracil,
we just need to remove this methyl group,
so I'll do it and replace it with hydrogen.
It is understood that hydrogen is here.
We now have uracil.
We see that uracil and thymine are very close molecules
or very similar nitrogen bases,
so they can perform similar functions.
Uracil is associated with
adenine like thymine.
Everything else, of course, remains the same.
An interesting question is - why uracil? Why not a Tymin?
Or why tire? Why did not uracil?
Based on what I've read, it turns out,
that uracil creates more premise for mistakes.
It can be related to different things.
He's a little more unstable than he is.
Ie. uracil makes the RNA molecule
or the information exchange machine,
less stable.
This is a more unstable way of transferring information.
In evolutionary history
RNA is thought to precede DNA.
In the early evolutionary stages there have been many changes,
then the uracil was appropriate,
there have been many mistakes in the transfer of information, and so on.
But then it became necessary information to be a little more sustainable,
and to have fewer preconditions for errors in its transmission.
Then Tymin helped stabilize things.
There is also such a question, "Why has the uracil been preserved?"
RNA molecules have many different roles in the cell.
The information RNA gets information
of the DNA and transcribes it,
to be translated using ribosomes.
But mRNA should not be stuck forever to the ribosomes.
We want it to be a little unstable.
So this is an interesting question of reflection.
Why do we have uracil instead of thymine?
or why do we have thymine instead of uracil?
Urticle is one of the clearest signs,
that we have an RNA molecule.
So what we have on the left,
all this,
let's do it in a different color,
all this, this circuit here,
as illustrated,
can be regarded as RNA.
Assuming that this happened during transcription,
when one DNA chain wants it
to copy your information,
then this will be mRNA, information RNA.
Think what's going on here?
Consider the orientation of the information RNA,
we have a phosphate group,
then 5 & apos; carbon, 4 & apos ;, 3 & apos; and a phosphate group,
then a 5 ', 4', 3 'and a phosphate group,
The chain is oriented from 5 '(up) to 3' (below)
and these DNA molecules are oriented in the opposite direction.
It is a carbon atom 5 '. It is a 3 'carbon atom,
so we have phosphate, 3 ', 5', phosphate,
we have 3 'up and 5' down.
With the help of the names of the nitrogen bases,
we see that we have mRNA,
this is its 5 'end, and this is the 3' end,
the above nitrogen base here is uracil.
And the second is cytosine.
It's cytosine.
This is cytosine here and this is transcribed
of the DNA molecule on the right,
so this is DNA and this DNA has an antiparallel orientation.
It is parallel but turned upside down.
Sugars point in the opposite direction,
so this is the 3 'end.
This is the 5 'end.
We see that uracil is attached to adenine via a hydrogen bond.
This is adenine.
I'll draw dashed lines to indicate hydrogen bonds.
Cytosine is bound by hydrogen bonds with guanine.
This is guanine here.
I'll make the hydrogen bonds in white.
There are several hydrogen bonds here,
but to be clear, this is mRNA,
and on the right we have DNA.
This can happen during transcription.
What kind of RNA is there?
We have talked about it in other videos too.
We have an information RNA that plays an important role
when copying information from DNA,
to be translated
with mRNA in the ribosomes.
I have just mentioned another type of RNA,
transport RNA - mRNA.
In the general video for transcription and translation,
we are talking about the mRNA functions,
it binds amino acids at one end
and there are anticodon at the other end.
Anticodons bind to mRNA codons,
in this way, proteins can be built up.
This is a visualization here
of the mRNA molecule.
Often, when we think of DNA,
we say, well, mRNA or RNA is a mediator
thanks to which DNA information is translated into protein.
but sometimes
we want the RNA itself.
RNA itself plays a role in the cage
beyond simple transmission of information
and one example is mRNA.
You can see that there is an interesting configuration,
in which the amino acid binds approximately in that region,
and the anticodon are
in the lower right corner.
The different mRNA molecules will bind to
different amino acids
and will have different anticodins.
This is another function of RNA.
There is also ribosomal RNA,
it plays a structural role in ribosomes,
where translation takes place.
There is also a microRNA,
these are short RNA chains,
which can be used to adjust the translation
of other RNA molecules.
DNA gets a lot of attention,
but RNA is very, very, very important,
many people believe RNA has emerged first
and the first life is likely
or pseudo-life ever consisted of self-replicating RNA molecules.
It is also possible that DNA has evolved from RNA,
but RNA has remained, as it is still very useful.